that's a bear it's a cute bear cub ah
it's a cute really cute bear
you wanna be my cousin wife what but oh
my god their spells look at the control
key by press eat a fart that must be
your first spell oh yes I'm here
I see to get a reward beast win I have
no idea what's happening oh yeah dance
baby oh I am wait wait I'm coming
I didn't know that was actually I
thought that was wait wait wait wait
wait wait oh heck yeah two different
songs wait guys guys guys I see a Grim
Reaper in the distance is that bad
that's fine oh I press G we're starting
whatever that means we're starting the
game wasn't starting G to start game I'm
sorry oh I'm still dancing I like it I
see a ghost bless you I guess are we
getting points for okay that's useful
wait find a good find of just press C to
get a reward beast wins you win Wow oh
here we go
whoa hello I'm a bear oh oh hey Mark hey
wait I came to bury a move am I supposed
to be able to move I know I sneeze so
what are we supposed to do to win oh wow
q why can't why can't I move well let's
go find this bear where are you what do
you see I'm in a corner I'm in a corner
by a church over here I think I think I
songs light with really bright blue
running while you're doing it I think
you can't move I can't move
can you guys oh don't don't don't sleep
if you press buttons does it work now
I'm pressing all the buttons did my
camera died oh it did didn't it oh my
god it wasn't plugged in okay I'm back
hey what'd I miss your left well I miss
bunny why is he a bunny I did my
computer freaked out in the game crashed
when he came back as a bunny
I don't know and Mark what did you do to
us look man it looked interesting wait
did you pick this map or something I did
I can select a different one we three
make the server though which I wanted I
let's do that yeah let's do that
breathe I breathe hurts I was just
trying to play video games where did you
find this what is this you mark so hey
guys there's a store for this game week
there's characters yeah I saw we need
more coins a press C to get reward
beasts win why does beasts win what
just okay get the reward yeah claim your
reward what a sweet reward mark how do
you do your cue you can't do it until
the game starts I below yeah I'm the
Beast all right
come and get us beast you'll never find
us
I'm already gotten you so I made a
mistake
yeah I broke myself by trying to try out
the right-click apparently the
right-click makes it so you can no
longer
move or function oh well that would
explain what happened to me probably
where you go I'm in a cave somewhere oh
god oh god I see you idle screen bear
man if I can get you guys you may get me
give it do it Gibby do it you won't get
luck no balls you won't no balls no
balls you won't you won't do it no come
on I'll stick my head in your mouth here
we go yeah
can you play music from inside of me
always we're getting points we're
getting points for this yeah you got to
put the bear to sleep I think I think
that's the objective the right-click is
just a picture of the bear apparently
that means you're just a picture of a
bear the rest of the game rather than
wait three minutes I'm just gonna end my
misery
use the right-click I don't know the
other ones this game can I say that I
love this are you enjoying just give it
a chance unless you can sing me a song
about why I should give it a chance
right now I will not this game is made
by a person with hopes and dreams and
they just want to make a game for people
to love and you're [ __ ] on their
dreams and I will not stand for it
you sock Bob so give this game much
[Music]
attacking me seemed excessive but the
rest that was pretty convincing all
right start this game let's get it going
are you gonna within no I'm in this
level so pink blossom was too green so
that's why I went do this wanna stay oh
wow I'm a panda I think he's a panda
buff so basically you just want to hold
the music on I'm getting points right
now you're getting my Q button still
doesn't work so that's just something I
don't get to use hello that didn't do
anything
guys this amazing game pop my Q and got
nothing for it murder
hurt people is a better listen just cuz
you guys don't know the ins and outs of
being a bear doesn't mean that I okay
look mark I figured out the strategy
okay come are you except your IQ button
doesn't work out yeah it's good Wade
picked a dumb map that's suddenly it
seems don't work anymore
nothing has ever worked for anyone but
you I am having a great time did you
hear my sneeze yeah doesn't even a cloud
sounds like a you boy alright don't
right click Bob don't like like don't
right click I got a cloud what are these
stars vomiting out of oh it's neat this
is all I can do I'm just gonna do it
okay yeah you can't give me closer
comfort if you press space you launch in
the air oh I've tried it already you got
to be running while you do it
no I fried it already all right
man just get out hey I I could literally
do nothing but play songs for you that's
all you gotta do you got to soothe the
savage beast see this game's deep
intricate lore you guys aren't
appreciating it finish me I don't want
to live in this world wait can I eat you
come here I'm a bunny you're a bear we
go together like pie and mouth
hey aren't pandas like vegetarians some
like that I'm bamboo disguised as a
bunny oh hey look I want as the Beast
what time to be alive oh man I can't see
how around three goes next round baby
I'm having a great time you guys are
just sticks in the muds who don't know a
good time if it came up and bit you in
the rump
who will end which one of you is human I
am mark I think we need to hide all
right we're inside okay but I'm a human
who are we hiding from mark I think we
need to come with me and go inside the
big building okay
all right then Who am I following into
where there seems to be a bear behind me
bear seemed play stupid well all right I
can't do that hold on I'm gonna find
something I can do uh-huh right click
okay Bob you got a bear coming your way
hang on I'm using my super speed yeah
it's the same speed but I'm push the
button for my sneeze she's not working
hang on hang on I got a wind-up hang on
give me a second all right okay give me
a second I got it that guy sneeze yeah
he snuck it's not coming out hang on all
right well I'm glad you know you missed
thank you and I feel like the humans are
a little overpowered in this baby next
round keep the pain train going
right as long as it'll press any buttons
I can be a bear sprit I can sprint and I
can move I need to test something on you
boy do we win if the time runs out is
that what we're aiming for yeah I think
so we just trying to evade the bear
situation yeah see it's a game so good
at this game never gonna get me Bob win
I'm doing stuff oh wow that's crazy just
now I'm gonna be real brave here when we
fight Bob I'm gonna right click all
right sure you'll never find me I've
already given up I feel like Bob Sue's
me maybe I use the game bag soothe me I
think you gotta be within a certain
radius to get the soon honk points I'm
getting column points hold on I'm oh god
I like this this is going well hold on
that's a good oh come on with your
bridge you're lucky it takes me 10
minutes to go up that's just because
you're bad at the game come on man what
oh no
wait could take advantage of these
moments when yeah they're like that are
you [ __ ] serious progress bar there's
no indication that I've done anything to
you except that I got you all those
talents I was close I was what do you
mean by that I'm making it a hug
I think you understand no we when we
were playing earlier we played it enough
that the bear turned into a rabbit and
then humans won don't you remember no
that's what happened no it is not oh my
god that is not what happened there is a
game here if you none of that ever
happened your life what are we supposed
to do when the bears all put our
business in the first place you've got
ability
I don't sprint and the cooldown for Q
pops up like I used it but nothing
happened I don't know what's wrong with
your game then it's your game mark it's
our guess is your game I love this game
it's cause you [ __ ] are sticks in
the mud I think you're just doing it
wrong we have to press Q does it I can't
even press E it won't even trigger the
fake not working
hey I did the right click and it it
works for you Oh to make this game so
that it only works properly on his
computer combination I don't know why
you guys's buttons don't work but mine
were fine I am having the time of my
life maybe you should make the server
mark maybe maybe maybe server Award for
use okay all right okay I will I will do
that wow this one's beautiful it's
beautiful can't wait to have fun with my
friends they're gonna be in the store
for any minute now art can you invite us
I just not working okay and you just
click the button to enjoy this part I'm
getting there Bob it takes a second I
can't join your game bumbum invited you
to play I will leave you why
you're steamed [ __ ] are you broken what
is happening look it's because this for
some reason this game launches steamvr
well when I'm playing haha if you could
tell me how to turn that off I would
love you forever because for some reason
steamvr always loads when I play random
ass games do you click on seen VR when
you launch the game no make sure I'm
pretty sure maybe that's what we're not
broken because you're playing VR VR
don't know how to get out of VR once it
gets in because then in my suit on the
phrase VR but you don't know how to get
out of here because you're in VR no I'm
not in VR just says I'm in VR how do you
get how do you stop that from happening
the whole steamvr thing is extremely
annoying
oh just don't click on seeing me are
nice no I haven't Bob Wally I got food
while we're waiting for mark to fix his
broken game so nice and I'm playing the
worst game ever can't find your server
I'm restarting see I'm not even there
I'm gonna make a server ok ok if I
launch this game it starts to be ry and
then it puts me in friends VR like in
the friends Benny and there's no way to
get rid of that [ __ ] I can't create a
server relaunch your game they did that
to me before I've realized my game four
times all right and then it must be love
I don't know
power love will help you okay I'm in I'm
trying to go to steamvr settings but now
the settings won't even open why won't
the settings open let me get to the
settings open settings settings this is
where the settings would open it's this
game malware I think it's not opening
settings because my VR isn't plugged in
how's it going mark is it working mark
is it working hello I think marks gonna
play VR so no and it's plugged in now
settings won't alright I'm just gonna go
to steamvr
there's it's it will not open steam
settings or VR settings it's you guys I
I'm just eating a sandwich
all right yeah there's the settings oh
look at that the settings okay ah ha ha
ha mark did you click on scene VR
settings you know what I'm starting to
come around on this game I like this
part there's no option in here well it's
the settings it's not the options Bob
I'm really trying here I'm actually
trying here
are you really legitimately trying to
make this work for us I'm trying to help
you mark I was just telling you that's
not no you're not you're intentionally
being an [ __ ] if you click on steamvr
settings you are being a douchebag and I
don't know why I'm here with you ma'am
I'm trying to work it out they keep
choking on my chicken it's just nice
what it's not me involved for once
we'll get there mark don't you worry
about it if you uninstall steamvr it
should fix it you know that's what I'm
gonna have to do because there's really
no other option at this point I'll
reinstall it every time I want to play
the steam VR is gone
is there a server did someone else make
server ah no I was looking you make it
and then Bob said he was gonna make it
I'm unable to make a server still ok I'm
gonna make a server I'm it says I'm in
friends VR oh I need a research team
this is gonna fix it this is the one I'm
shutting off steam I no longer have er
installed using a VR headset install via
no I'm not using it for y'all
it keeps loading me into friends VR I
cannot believe this
okay I am looking into my desktops
processes I'm looking for a latent
steamvr oculus what you know mark I was
wrong about this game I'm sorry that I
judged it so harshly
I am uninstalling oculus yes I'm sure
that I want to install okay it's done
okay it's done it's done so if I load up
this game no VR I'm free guys we can
play the game now guys I'm playing
destiny - are we are we moving on guys
play the game you want to uh try your
server there again mark and make it this
time
I'm making it I'm making it I make it
alright this is gonna be so on you may
need to send out invites again cuz like
the fine game oh yeah yeah yeah of
course of course of course of course
invited you to play I'm waiting I'm
waiting it's gonna be so much fun get in
here yeah I can't do it how about
finding finding the server you find the
server November fine game just let it go
for a bit it's it's there okay yeah I'm
sure it's coming oh why is the game
running at two frames a second you talk
smack about this game that's so good
like a bag of tits no have you seen the
bear model I will not stand for you
tearing down this man still don't show
up and I am online in a game mark it
just says you're online you're still
talking about
no I'm not I'm here I'm so here I don't
hear the doubt I'm gonna close my game
I'm gonna relaunch steam okay yeah I
guess I'll restart steam that we already
think work was talking about all right
good news guys the server is up great
I'm racing in full speed right now here
we go here we go when I click on play oh
oh oh I think I'm here do not password
protected I did I just got a passport
nice problem oh well whatever more the
merrier we can get you guys like you
worked oh I can't see you I'm gonna get
you forget school that's cool what gonna
get you imma get you guys do you see
guys this evening for big snez Wow good
evening we're playing this game if we've
only been trying to play it for 45
minutes it's a beautiful thing it's so
pretty it's kind of pretty in there I am
covered for you oh no did I get you you
got me all right Bob I'm coming for you
you can't jump as the rabbit and I like
to think rabbits you know hop as part of
their fathers I would expect that
gotcha what's that yes I win all right
next round you really were with me over
mark you know there were some troubles
there were some tribulations that was so
much fun
that's a fun it's still fun I can't
believe I doubted you
it's so much fun right that was just so
painfully fun I know it hurts to laugh
my face literally hurts from the huge
boom I chase you
yeah you're lucky I was gonna get you
I know oh you're still still my good B
hello to eyes I did that what does it
ever do why am i laughing I don't know I
was gonna get you you're lucky you did
that thing
wait wait wait wait listen listen listen
listen listen listen I'm listening oh my
god yeah I set the runaway it sneeze at
me yep always every time well what else
would I be doing well be my friend no no
no no I'll be your friend Wade okay I
don't feel successfully friended isn't
that how friends is that's how all my
friends were in middle school nice boy
it didn't work out yeah my rabbit's foot
oh my god I've got a speed bug oh my god
I wrap it so fast oh my god mark is a
glitchy ribes so fast yeah my sprint
only activated my bunny what does that
even
what does that do just make it laugh
what the hell okay well you just seem to
touch me and I died people in here now
people oh hell yeah more people yeah so
what makes it fun yeah no that's good
that's good the bear I am again
apparently waiter these are all like a
high level people wait they're all
different characters there yeah maybe
these are all the good players on this
game there's actually a pretty big
eSports scene
you wouldn't expect it but you know how
polish the game feels that's because
it's actually got a really big
competitive scene uh-huh okay with more
people on the server the music in this
game is a [ __ ] nightmare I love it so
much fun man
I'm the beragon well I'll never get to
be the bear I guess so I'll never get to
win here I come ready oh wow did you
roar there was a huge red sphere that
emanated from the cave I'm coming from
case you're curious come at me what
you're gonna do eat me
know what's gonna not today
would you stop focusing on me would you
go is this you well someone else eat
someone else alright thanks for you here
look right you like that
well it's pretty good I like this can
you doubt myself a little bit really
glad you like three feet look look man
look look man look look where you went I
can't sleep through all these trees
you're lucky they're here okay okay good
good this is tricky I can consider
myself a very lucky person beside to
sneeze it's not good yeah I think it
just stops us from playing music at all
Wow okay you cut me off there yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah you called my bluff to
jump down and in front of me but like I
appreciated you doing it yeah yeah I am
very fast
I am so fast how's this your bomb maybe
I'll stop him I didn't stop him save me
bunnies I can't
it seems he's very strong you can't cut
me off for murder me or anything try my
best
I'm nibbling at your ankles well there's
the other players oh there there well
why can't you get them wait why why can
you only get me oh they were right there
Wade you just
when you had your chance alright Wade
this is really pathetic that was that's
the most romantic thing I've ever seen
in my life hi oh there's three other
people over there wait why am I the only
one you've ever killed you came to kill
no one else is their ability to make me
see like ten clones of them or something
maybe oh maybe that's it that might be
it might just be the one to unlock other
claw other other abilities and things
yeah yeah when you buy the other
characters they have each their own
special ability
[Music]
almost Wade super sick I don't know if
it's like my skills a human is really
terrible but you know really had a
better showing of this when you were
hunting me Wade yeah Bob's making you
look like a fool yeah
hey twenty seconds and the humans went
wow that lady was right there oh my god
my company's noses yeah she definitely
has like some kind of weird clone thing
yeah I've pounced on them like one just
went into the ground oh wow yeah when do
you get more experience and more song
you play I think you get points yeah the
bear ever man you get caught on a lot of
[ __ ] in this game not me man
just cuz I love this game so much played
all the time hi hey how you doing Oh
what wait what what what what what Oh
least I'm human now Bobby are you the
bear no oh oh no that means the other
person is it bear I don't think they're
gonna be as bad as Wade is
oh hey they nailed me with a jump then
again I was standing right there so I
didn't I didn't exactly do a whole lot
but I didn't think they would get me
that good I would love to know the
thought process by which they landed at
we need a Cloe need a cloud of smoke for
escapes big-time sneeze
god damn it makes sense to me I guess
hey well you might know it's a bunny
okay well Bob good points I believe that
you'll be the bear this time I think so
I believe it I'm the bear all right
Bobby having fun dude this is my new
okay I'm actually now that it's working
I am having a little fun that was scary
oh-ho-ho Bob wait wait listen you do not
have to do this thank you Bob you're so
merciful oh my god that jumps me pretty
good there Bob oh my god
I got what do you do spank our way this
tissue of me good it's good it's so good
oh god wait is it just me oh I will I
will I will I will
oh no god oh god
oh please wait Bob mercy mercy on me my
mercies all of my mercies I've got so
much mercy okay well you know I just
wanted some points tricky Rock oh please
wait not like this
[Music]
okay strapless they're left oh oh oh oh
it's just you okay all right well I
never want to be the bear again or
humankind's always be rabid like what
are you ready cave gym you guys want to
play gonna do one before you know what
mark
as the bear with all the abilities
working had a sincere fun just now for
like several moments I just want you to
know I gave you a really hard time about
this and I feel kind of bad about that
now because that's not your fault the
game didn't work your for the games [ __ ]
thought it was VR kept opening it's not
none of that is your fault I'd say I
sincerely had moderate amount of fun
wait know if you guys are friends again
that means I'm gonna be the but again no
all right happy thanks Bob Nirvana means
a lot let's move on to something that
waves bad at okay see that's not hard to
balance don't be good but all right
suddenly every game
[Music]